there is like no one out there right now
that is on Jenna Ortega's level this
girl should be legendary for the extreme
levels of prep work she put into her
work especially if we're talking about
Wednesday like she might have actually
gone too far with that one hey you get
over here I have a lot of anxiety in my
life but there's nothing like
auditioning for a play or a movie so for
a textbook over preparer like Jenna
Ortega you'd think that auditioning for
Wednesday was a total nightmare well it
turns out that sometimes you don't need
to prepare so much if you just really
commit to a crazy idea that comes to you
in the Moment Like apparently her
audition came the exact same day that
she was filming her bloody end of the
movie scene for X yeah there are a ton
of really stressful stories out there
from famous actors who had to audition
the same day as they were shooting and
let's just say it sucks for Jenna though
it was perfect instead of changing or
getting a shower like a normal person
would she decided to show up to her
audition still covered in fake blood I
wore prosthetic I had Cuts all over my
face and Stage blood and sweat in my
hair and anyone who has seen X knows
that we're not talking about like a
small amount of blood here not only that
but she'd been awake for like over 24
hours already she was
disgusting for any other audition this
probably would have been a red flag for
Wednesday though the only thing better
would be if she showed up with a cello
and a bag full of piranhas like I just
like to imagine what it was like for
everyone else who saw her on the zoom
call meeting Tim Burton covered in fake
blood is about the best idea I've ever
heard and like something tells me that
he met Helena Bonham Carter in a very
similar way though maybe not with the
fake blood of course this much
Excellence bounced back on Jenna when
you set that bar that High people just
expect that level of commitment from you
24 7. so before we get into how Jenna
Ortega nearly lost her mind playing when
Tuesday take a brief second to like And
subscribe for more of Jenna Ortega's
best stories Wednesday Adams is a true
genius who is good at pretty much
everything from playing the cello to
fencing to solving Mysteries and on and
on and on so playing her requires the
amount of dedication you normally see
from some super crazy I mean Super
committed actors like Christian Bale or
Daniel Day-Lewis like just listen to how
intense a typical Day filming Wednesday
was she had to get to set several hours
early to make sure that iconic Wednesday
Adam's look was perfect then they shot
for like 14 hours and I've seen all of
Wednesday like three times now and there
are only like half a dozen scenes in the
whole season that she's not even in and
these are intense episodes too a ton of
fight scenes monologues and Chase
sequences not to mention the whole
episode she spent in a high-speed boat
race I'm sure that that was a a super
fun week and she had to do all that with
an added challenge that few other actors
have ever faced she wasn't allowed to
Blink yeah Jenna impressed Tim Burton by
limiting her blinks so much that he
encouraged her to pretty much stop
blinking altogether and as you might
expect this was pretty annoying though
there is a secret are you ready the
secret strategy Jenna used during her
Wednesday shoots was that any time it
felt like she needed to Blink she just
didn't blink go ahead and try it for a
minute Annoying right yeah that's all
there is to it like no wonder she was so
good at being perpetually unamused for
those giant 12-hour days so normally
that would be the end of it she could
just go home and blink and smile all
night if she wanted to but not for Jenna
it was just the beginning there would
just be more Wednesday work waiting for
her when she got home like she had
lessons set up for her at home sometimes
there would be Zoom calls that ran her
through a fencing lesson some fight
choreographer fee or any of the other 8
000 things she had to do for the show
and the most extreme training she had to
do was cello lessons for that they
actually had an instructor sent to her
home things were so bad that she was
Sleepless delirious and frantically
crying from overwork she said that she
was practically pulling her hair out and
that didn't dull her passion for the
project though in fact she had to go
like full Diva mode to ensure that
Wednesday really felt like Wednesday
recently she confessed she was
borderline unprofessional on set because
she flat out refused to do lines that
she felt won against Wednesday's type
there were scenes where she was gushing
over an outfit or emoting too much and
Jenna would just go nope this is wrong
she then pretty much rewrite the scene
to fit Wednesday's character we want to
up kind of the horror aspect a little
bit and then get Wednesday out of the
Romantic situation and now that she's
been crowned as the best Wednesday Adams
of all time I'm guessing that she's
basically gonna deserve a writer's
credit for season two when it comes to
the show she's basically at the Robert
Downey Jr level of stardom there's no
winning an argument with her about what
Wednesday would say and if that wasn't
enough you may not have realized that I
left out the most important part that
Wednesday dance well don't worry Jenna
totally forgot about it too like
normally they would actually hire a
choreographer to create an iconic dance
like the one that dominated Tick Tock
forever not this time nope apparently it
was all put on Jenna Ortega's shoulders
she was so delirious from her daily
schedule that when Tim came up to her to
tell her he had full confidence that she
was gonna nail the big dance number
coming up she boldface lied straight to
Tim Burton that she had it down yeah she
had nothing she studied everything she
could get her hands on like classic goth
dance moves from the club scene the
original Wednesday's Shuffle and plenty
of her own favorite moves you know how
that dance is basically Jenna Ortega
going through like an entire time warp
worth of quirky dance moves while Tyler
just stands there awkwardly well yeah
that's because all she did was string
together the only moves she had time to
practice and man did it work even the
Netflix execs told her that this was
gonna be huge she didn't believe it
though even today she refuses to do any
of the moves when every single
interviewer ever asks her she probably
still gets flashbacks not every
interview can be quite as cool as
meeting Drew Barrymore though it's like
meeting the Statue of Liberty this
is crazy that 22
reboot sequel was supposed to be a
vehicle for poor Melissa Barrera AKA
that girl from Scream who wasn't Jenna
Ortega like my favorite part of any
Scream movie is the opening sequence
Drew Barrymore's might be the most
famous but my favorite is the Jada
Pinkett Smith one from scream 2. like
that scene in the movie theater always
freaks me out so this is one of the only
things Jenna and I disagree on though I
assume for her big scream opening scene
she went hard on the scream study sesh
she watched all the movies but mostly
focused on Drew Barrymore's famous
performance in that first film and like
she even got to gush to Drew herself on
her own talk show I told him I was like
guys I'm talking with Drew should I just
spoil the whole film though I'm not sure
if Drew was flattered or a little
freaked out over how much Jenna studied
her for scream it seems like it was a
little bit of both was there any part
she didn't have to study that hard for I
can get really dark really fast and it's
kind of spontaneous and I think that
that might intimidate people evidently
there's only one role she felt like she
really didn't have to go full Hermione
actually it's 2023 maybe not a Harry
Potter reference there was only one role
she felt like she didn't have to go full
Emma Watson for yeah that works
evidently Thai West the genius behind
the X Trilogy is so meticulous that no
one in the cast felt the least bit
anxious that they didn't know what he
expected from them they were all a big
part of the process so there was no need
for Jenna to have to take cello lessons
for this one I mean what would she have
done watched x-rated films and the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre every single day
there's no way she ever would have
recovered from that she even went so far
as to admit that she'll never be in a
movie quite like X again I'm sure she's
already terrified of season two of
Wednesday Adams I mean I kinda am for
her now after seeing them together at
the SAG Awards I'm really hoping Aubry
Plaza comes on Wednesday to play like
her in the future or something but like
what do you think
[Music]